au dernier forum économique mondial à
davos les mots quatrième révolution
industrielle était sur toutes les lèvres
une révolution qui dit on est à nos
portes et qui sera faite d'intelligence
artificielle et de robots une révolution
qui pourrait exercer une pression à la
baisse sur l'emploi bonsoir mathieu sa
cellule est-ce qu'il menace réelle au
monde du travail avec cette révolution
qui dans certains corps de métier oui si
on regarde les chiffres qui ont été
compilées par l'université d'oxford ont
regardé ici les poste de réceptionniste
d'agent d'information assistant
juridique vendeur ait commis chauffeur
de taxi et de camions ainsi que les
gardes de sécurité sont des emplois qui
sont à risque d'être remplacé par
l'automatisation la population de robots
industriels c'est pas énorme c'est plus
de 300 milles au japon en amérique du
nord plus de 200000 même mais attendez
vous au cours des prochaines années
c'est une population qui va exploser qui
va aller dans tous les corps de métier
on compte mais maintenant des robots
psychologue
attendez vous à voir des robots dans
votre vie au cours des prochaines années
comment rester compétitifs comme société
face à ça qu'est ce qu'on fait il faut
comprendre que l'histoire du travail
anses une histoire d'avancées
technologiques on parle du silex là dans
la préhistoire jusqu'au machine à vapeur
à l'aube la révolution industrielle
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
qu'aujourd'hui pour avoir un emploi de
qualité faut savoir lire et écrire mais
dans le futur l'alphabet du futur ce
sera le code informatique c'est
peut-être à dessein que google
maintenant c'est renommée alphabet 1
c'est le nouveau nom de la compagnie
ouais ça en dit beaucoup dit long mais
même le métier de journalisme c'est
parce que vous avez suivi une formation
pour programmer un robot à écrire des
textes de nouvelles donc un robot
journée les robots journalistes dont tu
parles android c'est un algorithme
qu'est ce que c'est ce que j'ai fait
dans cette formation la fpjq c'est que
on code promotionnel des gens n'avaient
absolument ouais on code un robot à
écrire dans ce cas là c'était un texte
en réaction à une secousse sismique donc
on est allé piger dans une année de
données sismiques au canada pour écrire
un texte écouter le texte écrit en deux
secondes
vraiment impressionnant je suis bon je
sais que j'ai une tendance dans huit
journalistes savaient que la société
presse utilise déjà des robes aux
journalistes qui écrivent environ 3 des
3000 texte aux 15 minutes on vise 2000 à
la seconde
la seconde lors des dernières élections
départementales en france en 2014 le
monde avait utilisé des robots
journaliste pour écrire les nouvelles
sur les résultats dans 36000 communes
peut pas penser que le journal des
journalistes auraient pu écrire 36 mais
le texte dans un délai raisonnable les
textes de robots journalistes vous
enliser déjà ce sont des résultats
sportifs des résultats de cours de la
bourse
et plus ça va aller plus sont présents
plus ils créeront des textes complexes
alors attendez vous à ce que les robots
journalistes comme un peu partout
ailleurs est de plus en plus de place
dans notre société mais ils ne font pas
encore dans quel journaliste dont il n
est ce pas d'émissions de télé journal
22 heures encore fil des missions